when their grave disagreements about
what's good or bad in architecture and
art there's often someone around who's
keen to quickly close the discussion
down by saying beauty lies in the eye of
the beholder it's a phrase with the
power to silence once it's been uttered
adding anything else can seem a bit
shrill or just plain rude but in reality
the idea that beauty could be entirely
subjective is troublesome quite untrue
and plain dangerous for a start
no one believes it at the extremes of
the argument we know that some things
simply are just uglier than others and
we can tell by looking at tourist
figures that certain places to strike
millions of people as far prettier than
others
if the will of the majority can be
respected in politics then it should
also be respected in aesthetics even in
more ambiguous situations progress
towards some sort of resolution can be
made by using careful logic and patient
argument after all that's what we do
with other big topics like how to run
the economy or evaluate a hospital or
identify which one of two restaurants
might be the better we may not be able
to reach a conclusion that's
scientifically proven but non-scientific
agreement can be acceptable too we don't
need evidence from laboratories to agree
on the importance of family the
intelligence of Shakespeare or the charm
of the Alps so why insist that beauty
and art and architecture should be an
impossible subject to have any clear
views about the answer is actually
rather sinister the people who love our
doubts about beauty or one group in
particular property developers it's
extremely convenient for them to operate
in a society that has no confidence in
people's ability to make judgments about
whether things are beautiful or ugly if
there's no such thing as an objective
measure of beauty then you can pretty
much do whatever you like to a city or a
landscape and that's a lot cheaper we
shouldn't let a few areas of doubt over
beauty whether this will that chair
is more or less handsome for example
hijack the wider argument and lead the
reckless conclusion that all beauty is
always relative we must learn to stick
up publicly and sensibly for things that
a vast majority of us can see is more
beautiful so that we don't get exploited
and end up being condemned to living any
ugly environments that have become so
painfully common
you